[Music]
all right good morning everyone thank
you for coming to the confidential
computing session so the session is it's
all about security and privacy for the
cloud so it's it's great to have you
here and we we have sort of a very very
you know exciting group of speakers and
you know the the list of achievements in
the words that they have is so big that
I had to print up a you know a page of
paper just to remind myself so I think
it's going to be an exciting session the
first speaker is mark russinovich mark
is the chief technology officer for Asia
Xena is an expert on distributed systems
operating systems and he has you know
the the pleasure and the responsibility
of running one of the largest
distributed systems ever built by
mankind so it's a it's a tough job and
Mark is also an author of several books
I has ran startups so it has a sort of a
very broad range of experience and it's
going to tell us and we found out
yesterday Donald hasn't read my book
good good morning everybody
so this morning I'm going to talk to you
a little bit about what we call
confidence our computing and our vision
at Microsoft in Azure specifically with
MSR on how this technology is going to
evolve and eventually I think become a
standard for all computation I'll start
by talking about the way that we
approached it in Azure starting eight
years ago when I began in Azure even
back then people were looking at the
cloud skeptically for a lot of different
reasons but one of them of course a big
one was the security of their data in
the cloud the various threats that they
thought their data would be exposed to
if they stored their data in a cloud
provider where it's being managed by
somebody else including for example a
hacker breaking in through the
multi-tenancy boundary and getting
access to their data malicious insider
taking their data in and releasing it or
a third party coming and then through
legal means coercing or having the cloud
provider turn over the customers data
and all of these without the customers
knowledge and all of these we wanted to
make sure at Microsoft that as much as
possible we could stay protect the
customer data in light of these threats
and specifically for the legal requests
for customer data that we wouldn't be
put in the middle that it would be a
matter between law enforcement and the
customer and so we started looking at
how we could and increase the attention
of our data and if you take a look at
the way that cloud providers have
evolved the protection of data of course
one of the things we've seen over time
is that all of us have put in mechanisms
to encrypt data at rest
starting with system manage keys and
then adding key customer manage keys or
bring your own key solutions for
customers to protect their data we've
always encrypted our data in transit
between data centers and you're seeing
us introduce encryption even if the
customers data links are encrypted
within the data center and then the
missing piece though was how do we
protect the data while it's being
computed over these mechanisms where we
customer would store their data
encrypted in the cloud but then not be
able to compute over it are fairly
uninteresting to the customers and to us
at that point it's the cloud is just a
giant storage solution the customers
still left with providing computational
resources outside the cloud and having
to worry about transmitting data back
and forth if we could bring the
computation to the data center and still
protect the data then we'd achieve
protection of the data through all
aspects of its lifecycle so we saw the
development of what are called trusted
execution environments I believe
everybody in the room here is probably
familiar with them so I won't spend too
much time on them other than to say that
the interesting characteristics with
respect to the problems that we're
solving here are the fact that it's a
black box from outside the black box you
can't see what's going on inside the
black box ideally and the black box can
attest to what code is inside the black
box in a secure way and then the black
box can also steal secrets inside of
itself for later access the two examples
of enclaves that we've seen that
are in practical use for cloud providers
would be SGX which is part of Intel
processors and in virtual secure mode
which is a technology that was released
in Windows Server 2016
unlike SGX which is Hardware protection
of the data virtual secure mode is
hypervisor protection of the data so
even the hosts partition a privileged
partition a system administrator
wouldn't have access to the data being
protected by the virtual secure mode
blackbox now the trusted execution and
application architecture that we see
resulting from these technologies where
the Enclave weakest process isolation
sub process isolation the black box
actually lives within a process in the
operating system shares the address base
of that process so what's inside the
black box is portion of the address
space is trusted and from the outside
that's untrusted but the trusted portion
can reach outside of the black box and
access data for efficiency sake rather
than having to copy data back and forth
inside it can access encrypted data that
is outside the black box and this
requires a decomposition of the
application into this two pieces the
trusted portion and the untrusted
portion so as your confidence are
competing looking at these technologies
we realize that there's a lot more than
just making black boxes or SGX available
to customers or virtual secure mode
available to customers there's a lot of
other pieces that we needed to fill in
and so if you take a look at all of what
we consider confidence with computing
and Azure it consists of everything from
making these enclaves available and
we're we now have SGX cluster stood up
in Azure that we make available through
a limited preview form for customers
that sign up and want access to them we
also are working on an SDK that allows
developers nabel's developers to develop
these applications that are decomposed
into the untrusted and trusted portions
with a fairly easy way for them to
access functions from outside the black
box inside the black box and have the
underlying SDK runtime take care of the
transport and the transitions
between the Enclave and the outside
world we're also working on in
attestation services is of course
necessary for trusted code on the
outside to verify the integrity of the
trusted code on the ins in the inside of
the Enclave that at a station that comes
from the Enclave provider whether it's
the hypervisor or the hardware needs to
be validated someplace and that
validation is coming in the form of an
attestation service so we are in the
process of building an attestation
service one that will attest to SGX
enclaves as well as other enclaves
technologies as they come out so that
the software either inside the data
center outside the data center can
verify the authenticity integrity of
this code that's inside one of these
enclaves and that it's actually a
trusted Enclave finally one other aspect
of it is actually the two other aspects
that are work we need to mention are
that we're looking at also providing
confidence or competing capabilities
inside of our paths and SAS applications
as well so making it very easy for
customers to consume these rather than
having to build applications of course
all these are necessary from the
building blocks to create these
applications up and to finish services
that application end-users can take
advantage of when they're accessing and
their data or processing their data and
then finally one of the key aspects of
the collaboration with Microsoft
Research has been looking at how we can
harden these black boxes many most of
you know here that black boxes these
enclaves SGX specifically have been
subject to side-channel attacks and so
we're looking at ways to prevent leakage
of data outside of an enclave either
through tight channel or through
corruption of the enclaves code or
exploitation of bugs in the Enclave code
and that's an ongoing research problem
with Microsoft Word with MSR so speaking
of the information leaks the
side-channel attacks being able to look
at the execution of the Enclave from the
outside seeing its behavior through page
faults memory accesses this is one of
the examples of a side channel leakage
that can potentially reveal information
about the data that's being processed
inside the black boxes one of the papers
that struck me as fascinating was one by
Microsoft Research where that by looking
at page faults they were able to reverse
engineer the JPEG images being processed
by a JPEG decoder - close enough where
you could get a pretty good idea of what
the image look like and so these kinds
of problems we want to protect against
by having a verified runtime and
instrumented app application that does
two things one prevent the Enclave from
releasing secrets to the outside and the
other one is to prevent these
information leaks by looking at the side
channels of the execution from the
outside and so this is just a simple
example here of actually that should be
animating for some reason it's not but
the the idea is the data comes in and
depending on the tree different parts of
the address space or different cache
lines or pages are accessed and you can
reverse engineer which pass through the
decision tree the code took so I want to
show you an example of one of the
projects that MSR Cambridge has ongoing
which is oblivious computation the
protection against these inadvertent
side-channel leaks and I'm going to show
you by taking a look at support vector
machine execution and
did you change the password I did that
what don't I did that sorry about this
is secure login here to secure okay so
this is a the example first trace I'm
going to show you is a tool that
monitors the execution of memory
accesses and code accesses of the
support vector machine computation as
its processing data and you can see for
much of the time that these traces
actually do not line up based off the
two different inputs a and B and that is
an example of how we could look at the
differences or look at the trace
execution history and reverse-engineer
the data being processed by the the SVM
algorithm on the other hand version of
the SVM algorithm that's been fed
through the oblivious computation
compiler executes and no matter where we
stopped the trace you can see that the
trace pattern is exactly the same for
both data inputs a and B and so we view
this as one of the ways that we can help
our developers help developers protect
against leakage of side-channel attacks
and there's still a tremendous amount of
research going on going in this space
there's some performance overhead as you
would expect to this kind of oblivious
modification of the code and that
overhead varies depending on the
algorithm research work is ongoing to
minimize that overhead let's talk about
some of the examples of confidence or
computing that we're also exploring both
in the azure product group as well as
with MSR and start with one of them
which is always encrypted storage with
sequel server and let me talk a little
bit about that one I'll talk about
confidential block chains there's
financial data processing and their
secure multi-party machine
learning the when it comes to sequel
server the way that customers today
protect their data from access by the
cloud provider or by the host er is to
use a feature called sequel always
encrypted where they've have the key on
the client-side the sequel
runtime The Client runtime transparently
takes that key and encrypts data on the
way into the sequel server and decrypts
it on the way out so the data is always
in encrypted form on the backend in the
server the downsides of this though are
that the sequel server is not able to
see the data and therefore not able to
perform rich expressions on top of the
data some simple comparisons if you're
using a symmetric encryption algorithm
like equality are possible but certainly
not ranges and so what sequel
confidential sequel version have always
encrypted which is something we've
announced is coming and we're working
with the sequel product team to get into
released form the sequel data is
processed inside the database is engine
is store is executing sorry inside of an
enclave and the data is encrypted on the
way into the cloud and then the keys are
released after attestation of the sequel
engine to the sequel engine so that it
can process the data and then this case
you get arbitrary rich expressions just
like you would with unencrypted version
of sequel that data remains encrypted in
flight it remains encrypted and on disk
and it remains encrypted as it's being
computed over another scenario like I've
mentioned is confidential blockchain and
if you take a look at the way block
chains have evolved they started with
absolutely no confidential a
confidentiality at all so the Bitcoin
and aetherium networks everybody that's
participating in that at work and see
everything that's going on in fact
that's a property that's necessary for
the security of those networks and over
time we've seen different way paths
being explored for providing
confidentiality like side chains and
like zero knowledge proof
all of these add a significant amount of
complexity to the interactions with the
blockchain and the construction of the
blockchain and they have limitations as
well in terms of their scalability and
how much data then can be shared by the
network itself versus sent off into a
side chain that only the parties
involved with that can see and therefore
makes it very difficult to take that
data off those side chains and make it
available to other parties that weren't
part of that further zero knowledge
proof for example have a high
computational overhead and so that will
slow down the execution of the
blockchain by placing the blockchain
network within a network of trusted
execution environments where they attest
to each other the code that they're
running the parties that are governing
the individual nodes can certify which
code they trust including the blockchain
code as well as the cocoa runtime code
the cocoa being the project name for
this which stands for confidential
consortium that code establishes this
network and that implements the basic
runtime primitives that a blockchain
ledger can be layered on top of and this
includes secure storage of the
blockchain Network on disk as well as
the release secure release of this
information to parties that should have
access to it which makes possible a few
things one of them extremely high
transaction throughput and extremely low
latency because once you end up trusting
the nodes in this way the nodes trust
each other
you can fall back to crash tolerant
consensus algorithms as opposed to pbft
algorithms or proof-of-work algorithms
further because they're everything that
happens in the Enclave is trusted you
can program arbitrary confidentiality
rules into that code as through
governance policy one of the very common
scenarios we've heard is that multiple
parties are transacting with one another
inside the blockchain they should only
be able to see their own transactions
but there's an auditor that is part of
this consortium that needs to be able to
see the transactions of multiple parties
and so how do you set that up in a
dynamic way it's actually very
straightforward if you've got a network
this because you just implement those
confidentiality rules as you would in
any trusted Network which is simply
through access control policies where
the auditor has access to arbitrary
transactions in the code inside the
Enclave that's part of cocoa with the
blockchain primitives laid on top of it
would only make that those transactions
available to authorized parties so
confidentiality the governance can also
be built in to vote on which parties can
be added to the blockchain as well as to
evict parties all with very high
throughput and latency like I mentioned
this is a picture of the cocoa
architecture
now cocoa what we've done with cocoa is
I created a prototype last year that we
actually demonstrated publicly when we
announced a cocoa to the world the cocoa
prototype is evolved now and we're
building a production version of cocoa
this runtime like I mentioned arbitrary
block chains can be layered on top of
and so this initial prototype we're
layering the etherium blockchain on top
of it so it's compatible with
off-the-shelf aetherium though with
confidentiality attributes added to
aetherium so you can specify
confidentiality on top of smart
contracts this project we intend to make
completely open-source and we make that
means that customers can take this and
run it on their own servers outside of
azure the goal here isn't necessarily to
make sure that this is locked into Azure
or Microsoft only technologies it's
open-source the the Enclave runtime that
were working on will support both Linux
and Windows cocoa will eventually
support both Linux and Windows and it
will be published in github for other
parties to participate in the
development of it we also expect other
blockchain Ledger's to be integrated on
top of cocoa over time as well so let me
show you a quick example of cocoa and
what I'm going to do
last track of this one here we go no I
don't think so
yep it's locked up I don't know why it's
doing this this is a it's just SSH
session to a Linux machine that is
running in Azure and SGX machine
so what I'm going to do first is show a
simple smart contract oh thanks so I'm
going to show a simple smart contract
executed on the etherium Coco integrated
blockchain this is standing up a 5 node
aetherium network and then we'll execute
as many transactions as it can and then
show us the throughput that it achieves
and of course on the public version of
aetherium which is based off of
proof-of-work consensus the transaction
throughputs ten to fifteen transactions
per second you can see here then again
this is aetherium stock aetherium
integrated with Coco and it's achieving
you can see around twelve thousand
transactions thirteen thousand
transactions a second we've also just to
push the limits of the Coco framework
just created a simple ledger network and
then integrated that with Coco and this
is standing up a 5 node version of that
network and then also trying to see how
fast we can drive it and you'll see that
it's significantly higher than what we
got with aetherium and yet there's still
more performance optimization to do so
you can see that we're achieving close
to a hundred thousand transactions a
second we think we can get up to 150
thousand transactions a second or higher
in the five node network here and then
finally one of the last cases that we're
looking at this one's very exciting from
a number of different domains its
multi-party confidential machine
learning one of the canonical scenarios
for this is the processing of medical
data where different parties are coming
together with health information
gathered from different sources whether
x-rays it's cat-scans
diagnostic other diagnostic data these
parties are bringing it together and
they can get a deeper insight than any
one of them into
we can't but there's regulatory
restrictions or privacy concerns over
sharing their data with these other
parties with confidential computing and
these enclaves they can if they trust
the algorithms running inside the
Enclave release keys that make the
Enclave or enable the Enclave to access
their data and then perform this
multi-party computation over it and so
I'm going to switch back and show you a
very quick demo of that this is the
hospital scenario with three parties so
we have the server this is where the
training will happen
we've got hospital a we've got hospital
B and I'll show you a hospital a is
taking its plaintext data it's going to
encrypt it and then it's going to
encrypt it with the server it's key that
came from the Enclave and now the server
will process the data show the encrypted
model outside the Enclave and then when
we go back to hospital a whoops
hospital and you can see a hospital B's
getting back the encrypted weights and
decrypting them with its own key and
then showing them so in this case
hospital and Hospital B we're able to
get insights out of their data without
either one having access to each other's
data just trusting that machine learning
algorithm and the trusted execution of
arm and it was executing in so that's a
quick look at confidence are computing
the I fundamentally believe we
fundamentally believe in Azure that
we're at the the beginning of a
transformation of the way computing is
done today because of limitations in
Enclave technology we'll see this only
for very kind of extreme cases of
customer sensitivity over data we expect
that this will unlock data that would
otherwise not come to the cloud and
allow it to come to the cloud and but
that over time these primitives are so
power are powerful enough that we will
see the creation of basic effectively
the equivalent of these
private data centers on-prem data
centers within the public cloud
protected with through it with Enclave
technology also as part of our
intelligent edge intelligent cloud
strategy of course Enclave technology
will be critical on the edge to protect
data sensitive data as it's being
processed on it collected from those
edge devices so with that I wanna thank
you very much for taking a look at our
accomplished computing program a few
things I want to emphasize this is open
source tight collaboration with MSR we'd
like and seek collaboration with the
research community on these projects
that I've talked about there's a lot of
spaces to explore here and we don't
think we're gonna be the ones that can
do all of it so collaboration is
certainly welcome and I just want to
highlight men while Kosta where is he
where do you go oh there is right in
front of me from MSR Cambridge he has
been the lead collaborator with us in
Azure on this project so I'll turn go
ahead and turn over the next week oh
thanks let's thank mark I think we have
time for a couple of questions and then
all the speakers will be at around so
but let's let's keep the questions short
let's take two questions two
accelerators given that as yours now
incorporating accelerators and or more
to come that this is an area of ongoing
research I don't really have anything
more to say about other than we are
exploring how to do that of course the
machine learning example highlighted the
need for that that the training which is
not best done on CPUs but accelerators
is one of the big scenarios that we're
looking at very closely one more
question
thank you I'm a quick question
cookies coming something on the use of
homomorphic computing in Azure and how
practical that is not nowadays yeah so
that's another big effort in Microsoft
Research is homomorphic encryption and
we watched it the development of that
very closely as well it's got some
limitations it has performance overheads
as well associated with it we don't
think necessarily this is
one-size-fits-all its space in fact
homomorphic encryption inside of an
enclave the combination of the two is
something we're also looking at as ways
to extend the power of homomorphic
encryption all right let's think mark
again thank you very much thanks so our
next speaker is dawn song dawn is a
professor in the electric engineering
and computer science at Berkeley Dawn
has a very broad range of interests in
security
ranging from software security network
security distributed systems applied
crypto blockchain and machine learning
and security dawn received a very large
number of awards including the McArthur
fellowship the Guggenheim Fellowship the
NSA NSF Career Award slow and research
fellowship MIT MIT Technology Review
award in many others I would highlight
that dawn is ranked as the most cited
scholar in computer security so that's a
special achievement so we are very lucky
to have done here today thank you very
much and I'll end over to you thank you
thank you everyone for being here and
today i'll talk about towards secure
practical confidential computing with
open source secure Enclave and now
wearing two hats I'm a professor at UC
Berkeley in computer science department
and also I'm the founder CEO of a new
startup called Oasis labs
so here we hear a lot about the value of
data analytics and machine learning and
they can really bring us great power in
terms of gaining insights from data and
help us to make better decisions in many
different areas including healthcare
LG smart building many different and the
financial services many different areas
and also as we are now data is the new
oil unfortunately a lot of this data
also it's very sensitive so as we use
the data we need to be very very careful
with protecting users privacy so first
let's look at how current the framework
works for data analytics a machine
learning so how kind framework works is
that users data is being collected and
then the analyzer will write another
takes a machine learning program and
this program will then run on the
computation infrastructure which is an
computer results however the current
framework is insufficient for security
and privacy protections for a number of
reasons and in particular for several
different types of threats so the first
type of threats assets they here the
analytics and machine learning program
itself actually maybe untrusted because
there can be insider attacks and the
analyst accountant may have been
compromised and as the attacker can
actually interact with malicious
programs into the into the analysis and
machine learning program and also the
second threat as the computation
infrastructure itself may be untrusted
as well again attackers may have
compromised the computation
infrastructure and hence can distill
sensitive data during the computation
process and finally the computation
result itself can reveal sensitive
information about the inputs as well
because these computation results
actually are computed from the census of
inputs to start with enhance
the computation results itself may
reveal sensitive information about the
inputs as well so to address all these
three different types of threats we need
to develop different types of
technologies and this is something that
my group has been working in so and so
first to address the threats of
computation outputs rebuilding sensitive
information about the inputs we have
been developing technologies in
computing practical solutions for
differential privacy and for addressing
the threat of untrusted data analysis
and machine learning program and we have
been developing technologies for program
rewriting and verification so that so we
can actually automatically rewrite the
data analytics and machine learning and
pipelines and to ensure that even though
the original analytics a machining
program may be untrusted the rewritten
program will be insurance that I will
satisfy the desired the security and
privacy requirements and to address the
threats of untrusted the infrastructure
we leverage technologies for secure
computation given this session is
unconfident computing this is the area
that we will actually focus more in in
this talk the secure computation side I
wanted to show this overall picture just
to explain that when we do data analysis
and machine learning the privacy and
security and aspects it's actually a
fairly broad we need to actually protect
the security and privacy of data from
many different angles and not just
confidential computing and this
importance that we actually combine
these different technologies to to
really ensure the security and privacy
protection for users data but for this
talk we will mainly focus on adjusting
the second type of threats listed
using secure computation to protect
against untrusted infrastructure so the
concept of secure computation is very
simple and the goal is essentially to be
able to simulate a trusted third party
where essentially users data is being
used to compute a certain function with
this simulated chassis a third party we
can ensure that it from the computation
perspective uses data as being protected
so an attacker will not be able to see
more than in this case the computation
results and and and also in the squeezie
we also until you sure that the right
program is being executed and it does
the right things and one example
illustrating the importance of secure
computation as for example we want to
build a word
impact model from users text messages
and of course uses text messages are
really insensitive and as a computation
infrastructure may not be trusted so we
want to enable the secure computation so
that we can build the language model in
this case while preserving the privacy
of users text messages and we'll talk
about secure computers secure
computation there are two main types of
approaches the first one is crypto
cryptography based approach and the
second type is a hardware based approach
so with the crypto based secure
computation there are different
techniques including for a homomorphic
encryption as well as secure multi-party
computation the the Challenger for proto
based secure computation is that the
performance overheads can be very high
oftentimes it's orders of magnitudes
performance overhead compared to native
computation and this because of this
it's a significant element
the usage scenario for crypto based
secure computation the second type of
approach for secure computation is
hardware based in particular leveraging
secured hardware to enable an
abstraction that we call trusted
execution environments also called a
secure Enclave so in this case a secure
Enclave can provide and the capability
of hardware based isolation as well as
attestation and the advantage of secure
hardware is that it can provide a really
really performance and oftentimes the
performance over and the performance can
be very close to native computation and
hardware place to secure computation
century can enable very general-purpose
computation and can enable many
different security applications so again
so with the trusted secure execution
environments we essentially can run a
program inside the secure Enclave
and then in this case the operating
system and other processes running
outside of the secure Enclave they won't
be able to tamper with the execution
after program running inside and also
they won't be able to learn what's
running inside ideally and enhance
provides the integrity and
confidentiality and also the secure
anchor beacon in this case provide a
Hydra base the remote attestation
capability where and the secure Enclave
can attest to a remote user what program
hell is running inside the second clip
and what is initial state so secure
Enclave can serve as a really strong
cornerstone security primitive for us to
build secure systems on top of it can
provide very strong security
capabilities including authenticate
itself the device Authenticator what
program is running site
providing the integrity and
confidentiality of the execution and it
can really be a platform for beauty new
security applications that couldn't be
built otherwise for the same practical
performance and there has been many
example security applications and
systems built on top of secure Enclave
for example using interest reax
including a lot of great work done here
at Microsoft so besides this example
security applications that have been
demonstrated and the secure Enclave can
enable also here I want to just briefly
mention another user scenario where
secure Enclave can really help solving
even greater problems so here when the
nation state leaders have recognized and
the importance of AI and stated that
whoever can choose and leasing a I will
rule the world so the question is who is
controlling and leading AI today who
will be ruling the world tomorrow so
here this is the state status quo today
and usage data is being collected and
big companies build personal profiles
for users and then use these personal
profiles to serve users for example
providing driving directions are even
giving a job device and life plans
however a currently this in the setting
and these services their goal is to
maximize company revenue so the question
is is there a different future where we
can build intelligent agents and virtual
assistants
that are actually under user control
like a large services provided by third
parties and but
they retain the user profile and they
will be severe uses German directions to
Apple device and light plants and the
important difference here is that they
will be operating under the modes of
maximizing user value so the question is
is this possible how can we actually
achieve this so as I mention that I wear
two hats so as Isis we are building a
new technology called the
privacy-preserving smart contracts at
scale so what we do here is that we are
building a new block team platform and
on top of the blockchain platform one of
the key primitive and capability that we
provide as what we call privacy
preserving smart contracts and this
privacy preserving smart contracts has a
number of unique capabilities and
properties it can provide automatically
enforcement's of codified privacy
requirements so in this case the privacy
requirements actually will be encoded as
codes are inside the privacy preserving
smart contract and also we can achieve
the enforcement without relying on any
central party and so we plan to build us
privacy preserving smart contracts to be
able to scale to real world applications
including machine learning and even add
class scale and this primitive of
privacy preserving smart contracts can
make it much easier for developers to
build privacy preserving applications
without having to be a privacy expert
and to in order in order to enable this
privacy preserving smart contracts a
skill the Oasis platin platform provides
a number of different uses a number of
different technologies to provide this
capability including in
confidentiality preserving smart
contract execution which essentially
protects the execution after smart
contracted from leaking sensitive
information during the computation
process and also as application layer it
provides privacy preserving data
analytics and machine learning including
providing differential privacy for the
application to prevent the output after
computation from leaking sensitive
information about the inputs and we also
developed new architecture and
technology for the approaching platform
to enable scale ability to enable
scaleable smart contract execution and
with with this privacy preserving smart
contract technology we can build block
chain of intelligent smart contracts
where we can actually have various
machine learning smart contracts that
actually run on top of the blockchain
and always is floating platform and
these machine learning smart contracts
essentially can help pull data from
potentially mutually destructive
distrusted data sources and two together
then build for example differential rate
profits financial service models from
the session models or even medical
diagnosis and treatment models so one of
the key capabilities of enabling this
privacy-preserving smart contracts as
the ability to do confidentiality
preserving smart contract execution and
one of the key ingredients to enable
this confidentiality preserving smart
contract execution is to leverage the
capability of secure Hardware all the
hardware manufacturers have recognized
the importance of building secure
hardware so over the years they have all
been developing different solutions for
secure hardware including interesti ax
however today we still have lots of open
challenges in building secure hardware
so first how secure can I be under
warfare model and the water would
interested with the secure hardware and
for example yeah beacon keys your
financial data our health data in fact
this is our car a great challenge is can
we actually build a truly trustworthy
secure Enclave that can serve as a
cornerstone security primitive there can
be widely deployed and enable secure
systems to be build on top if we can
achieve this it can truly I share the
entire community into a new secure
computation era so what's the path to
trust what a secure Enclave there are
several important steps so first we need
an open source design for the secure
Enclave and ideally we would like to
have formal verification for the
security and correctness of the secure
Enclave and also we need to ensure
secure supply chain management and to
ensure the security of the manufacturing
process it's very important to have an
open-source secure unclear design
currently none of the commercial secure
Enclave RT solutions are open to the
public it has as the public we
educational analyze or verify a hardware
vendors design in the setting and also
currently there's no industry agreement
on what is the right solution for
building secure Enclave with the open
source a secure Android design its
provides the transparency that's needed
for the whole community to together
analyze and verify the security and the
correctness of the secure Enclave and to
enable high assurance and open source to
help build a whole community so there
has been great effort
built-in secure open-source secure
hardware
one example is centum from the Sunni
group from MIT which builds a secure
processor design using risk 5 high C and
and it's designed to be able to defend
against the cash based side channel
attacks so extending the centum we now
have a new project called the Keystone
in collaboration between Briana and MIT
and there are other institutions who
will be joining the team as well so the
Keystone and cliff is open source and
we're building open source a secure
Enclave on top of risk 5 and in
particularly leveraging the existing
physical hardware capabilities already
available in today's risk 5 chips and
the goal is to provide strong memory
isolation we wanted to be simple and
portable and provides a remote and
efficient capabilities and fully open
source there are a number of goals for
the Keystone design and that's four that
are important components to achieve
overall the goal of building a truly
trustworthy open-source secure Enclave
and I won't go into the specific
individual goals in detail and an
attorney will talk more about the side
channel aspects so so Keystone leverages
the existing physical hardware
capabilities into these risk 5 chips and
to compute the open source secure
Enclave and by using this the secure
Enclave
essentially helps to enable the system
to separate the privileged and trusts so
in particularly in the fix in this case
we actually have three modes the user
modes the supervisor mode and the
machine mode and
and also the components that enabled the
secure Enclave I ran at the machine
modes level where is the operating
system and running in the supervisor
mode and the users path other user
processes are running at the anti-de
user mode and one of the key components
for Keystone is the security monitor
which actually essentially helps
provides the memory isolation and in
particular we enable the physical memory
protection with the machine mode and the
virtual memory isolation with with the
ESMOD and the key so in particularly
relies on the the center risk five
primitives in particular there are two
main primitives that we rely on one is
the physical memory protection PMP and
the trap virtual memory TVM due to a
time limit I mean I won't have time to
go into the details for this but so
these hardware capabilities make it
actually much easier to provide the
memory isolation for for the secure
Enclave and as a result the Keystone
design for secure Enclave actually is
much simpler than for example as Jax and
also then centum as well so this is a
keystone architecture ok I won't have
time to go into the details right so I
actually skipped it and again because of
the fact that Keystone leverages
existing Hydra capabilities in risk 5
for the for the memory management's it's
actually the
it can provide much more flexibility in
terms of the type of unclaimed that they
can enable in the sense that the unclip
size can be dynamic and where the unclip
can be located is dynamic as well okay
so due to time limits I'll I think I
have to skip these these details and how
we actually use the PPM and the TVM to
enable the memory isolation and also
Keystone plans to use the the puffs to
help with the key management as well
okay so right with the as a
collaboration between Britain and MIT
and so we are working hard on the
building the Keystone secure Enclave and
so we have a timeline that we hope that
in the fall we actually we have a first
release after secure Enclave where it
won't be full featured in particular the
first release will contain some of the
key capabilities for from memory
isolation and some capabilities from the
secure post remote attestation and
secure key provisioning and we write so
we plan to actually deploy it first on
the Amazon interpreter using FPGA it's a
first deployment and later on we plan to
have have a deployed on the new hi-5
Unleashed chip so using such capability
for confidentiality preserving smart
country execution again we can enable
privacy preserving smart contracts and
the Oasis blogging platform
using this overall capabilities we hope
to truly enable a blocking of
intelligent smart contracts and here let
me just give you one example of a simple
application that we have been building
and together as collaboration with
researchers and doctors from eth and
Stanford's for an app called carrier a
privacy-preserving tokenize data market
for medical data so as well now medical
data is often locked in data silos so
the goal here is that we want to be able
to incentivize doctors and patients to
share data and to be able to improve
medical research and provision the
capability of privacy preserving smart
contracts on top of the OSS blockchain
platform so in this case users our
patients can upload their medical data
in the encrypted form to the Oasis
blockchain platform and then the medical
researchers can essentially build
privacy-preserving smart contracts and
within the smart contracts the
researchers can and includes machine
learning a model training a model
serving codes and also the privacy
preserving smart contracts can specify
Terms of Use for example how users may
get compensated for contributing their
data to the smart contracts and also
stating that for example the data will
only be used for training and machinee
model inside the smart contract and as
users agree with the Terms of Use
users medical data can be contributed to
the to the smart contracts at the smart
contract collects enough data it can
then and run the machinery model
changing codes to treat the missionary
models and in the end the medical
researchers can then evaluate the trend
machine learning models so in this way
and it helps to significantly reduce the
friction for medical researchers and
pharmaceutical companies to get access
to data for training
Machinery models to find better cures
for diseases and we have some upcoming
people at conferences and to summarize
for the technologies that have been
discussing and so Oasis labs and just
recently launched and also we have
launched our private testers where we
encourage and invite application
developers to join our private test nuts
to build applications on top of the
platform so the care example inventions
is actually a collaboration with some of
the top developers to build on top of
our platform and with other technologies
and the OSS laughs we hope to build a
privacy first high performance cloud
computing platform and blockchain and
others work for Keystone is in
collaboration between MIT and Berkeley
and we have a great team at Oasis labs
overall the goal is that we want to
build a truly trustworthy secure
hardware that can enable all these great
applications however submissions in the
talk there are many many challenges that
I actually didn't have time to go into
all the details so more resources are
needed for research and development and
it requires a community efforts so let's
check out the big challenges together
thank you thank you
we have time to for couple of questions
yes
I don't Great Auk how do you plan to
tackle the non technical issues for
example you talked about you know
verifying the supply chain for building
these chips and you know somebody may
trust the US regulated company like
Intel for example you know or whatever
and somebody may prefer EU regulated
company doing that and some other
Chinese regulated company like how do we
agree on these things that don't have to
do much with technology yeah that's a
great question so that's why that's
actually another reason why we want to
have open source secure Enclave so then
in this way we don't have to rely on any
single price so any hardware
manufacturer can then go manufacturers
and different users can also choose
which has where manufacturers that they
trust more than others
and also I do strongly believe that
while the whole community we actually
already have a lot of experience in many
of these other aspects of building
secure Enclave
but the secure supply chain management
is a one area where as a whole community
we actually haven't really tackle it
head-on we don't actually have a lot of
experiencing but it's a very very
important area so we hope that with the
Keystone project and also we are
actually hoping to build a community
together with different institutions and
the hardware manufacturers as a whole
community that actually can be a real
focus in the as a next step in the near
future and that we can put in the proper
processes and also various verification
procedures to help us to to make
progress towards this goal of secure
supply chain management right let's
think going again thank you
our next speaker is professor srini
Devdas from MIT is a Webster professor
of Electrical Engineering and computer
science Adam at MIT his interests are
also brought in computer security
computer architecture and applied crypto
srini received the the 2017 I Triple E W
Wallace McDowell award in the 2018 I
Triple E Charles a this our technical
achievement award for his research in
secure hardware he also received the MIT
s highest teaching honor the the Everett
mu biker Memorial Award in the Bose
Award for Excellence in teaching so
thank you very much and thanks for the
kind introduction
Manuel I want to give you folks a sense
of what is going to take to build secure
computer architectures that can do the
things that the previous two speakers
want to do but lightweight secure
enclaves and so on and it's fairly
challenging
they've been many attacks exploiting
side channels but not just side channel
attacks but attacks exploiting out of
order execution speculative execution
that have come out and I want to give
you a sense of how these attacks work
because we need to understand how these
attacks work in order to actually defend
against them so we've been working on
defenses against the latest and most
potent of these attacks I'll tell you a
little bit about that and I'll close
with talking about secure enclaves I'll
be brief because they've been covered
quite nicely by the by mark and Don but
the stakes are a little bit higher
because in the case of just building
conventional processors you get to trust
system software you get to trust the
operating system and you can make it do
work for you that corresponds to
handling sensitive data but you it can't
do that when you have a secure Enclave
if you want to minimize the trusted
computing base and you want to shrink it
down by whatever it is to three orders
of magnitude from tens of millions of
lines of code down to thousands of lines
of code so I'll say
a bit about that at the end so let me
just start so you're probably thinking
what is this picture well I had this
really pretty picture of that described
compartmentalization and secure
containers in in in processors and I
realized I probably illegally downloaded
that and so this is a picture of my tool
box and so so I own this picture and it
essentially gives you a sense more
seriously about what architectures have
to do architectures have to isolate
processes from each other this is
fundamental to multi processing it's
fundamental to time sharing right this
has been with us for 50 years and if
this is violated if architectural
isolation is violated we really have
nothing I mean we have no security we
have no privacy you don't have integrity
either and so it's important to maintain
architectural isolation and over the
years the computer manufacturers have
used many different performance
optimizations in order to improve your
IPC instructions per cycle etc and it
turns out these operations were done
largely at the micro architectural level
and they were hidden from the ISA the
instruction set architecture and in
particular these micro optimizations
have been shown to leak privacy and
potentially influence correctness as
well and so let me say a little bit
about the latest of these attacks
corresponding to spectrum meltdown that
have obviously received a lot of press
but very briefly here what one can do if
you want to just execute a sequential
program is obviously go from instruction
i to i plus 1 to i plus 2 etcetera and
every once in a while you're obviously
going to have a branch and that's
corresponds to control flow and you
could certainly wait until the branch
has been resolved so you know that you
want to go I in this left direction but
if in fact it takes a long time for the
branch to be resolved because you have
to go look at a memory location for
example then you might in fact decide to
speculate
so so you decide that that you're
probably going to go left and you decide
to take that left fork and you start
computing J and J plus one even before
you finish up on instruction I and if
you speculate correctly then everything
is great and you've gained performance
but if you miss speculated and you've
decided that what you really should be
doing is to go right I should say you
decided to go right but in fact you had
to go left then you've executed K and
potentially k plus one and you have to
roll back and you've done some things
that can clearly be cleaned up from a
standpoint of architectural state and
there's no question that processors
today I definitely do this cleanup but
unfortunately what happens is that while
you're executing K and K plus 1 in this
incorrect way or should I say in a Mis
speculated way you may have changed the
microarchitecture estate and that could
leak information so this notion of
speculation was considered just a
performance optimization but it has
serious security implications and
essentially the attacks that have been
proposed there's just a wide variety of
them I mean every conference seems to
have sessions now architecture
conferences or new types of attacks but
they have two characteristics in common
that first they primarily I exploit
cache tags shape state so you have
caches which are obviously important for
performance and they've been around for
a while
caches are micro architectural state and
you bring things into the cache when you
execute it for example the K and K
plus-1 incorrectly and that changes the
state of the cache and the cache state
unfortunately in speculation is not
rolled back in in conventional
processors and because you don't do that
there's some side effects to the miss
speculation the other thing that's
interesting is that you have branch
predictors in in computers that
correspond to deciding how to predict
which way to go whether to go left or
right and in this case you have a
situation where the learning associated
with the branch predictor I mean these
are not deep learning engines or at
least not yet but the
definitely have capabilities associated
with history cables etc and the inputs
to these branch predictors that
correspond to learning which way to go
for a particular branch may come from
other processes and so it's not just
that there's no isolation within the
branch predictors on learning from your
own process and that is actually also
being exploited by in these attacks so
there's really a huge attack surface and
so this is really a picture that I one
spends so much time on but you know I'll
leave you with in a spy's potentially
everywhere because you have processes
that are sharing branch tables processes
that are sharing caches DRAM controllers
there's timing channels cache tags and
so on and so forth so this is a fairly
exciting time in computer architecture
primarily because we have to go back and
rethink how we would do time sharing in
the context of all of these spies so I
want to give you a sense of how to
categorize these different attacks and
so here's a little picture that taxonomy
tzer's attacks corresponding to both the
new ones and the old ones and so the
idea here is that you have a domain you
have protection domains that's really
what time sharing is about so you have a
domain of a victim the victim has some
secret that the victim wants to touch
and use for encryption or maybe it's
just sensitive data medical records
what-have-you and then you have an
attacker the attacker is incompetently
using resources of the machine and it
may simply be a time shared situation
you may only have a single core but they
also could be multi course and they
could be space sharing as well so these
two domains are supposed to be separate
you have two different domains
corresponding to the victim and the
attacker and the first thing is that
there's these channels and these
channels are the side channels that have
to be created and then any number of
them in a cache tag state the but the
most common in in at least in current
day attacks but there are others as well
and what you what the attacker does is
it creates a receiver so this is really
a piece of code that can somehow
exfiltrate through this channel at the
secret or some form of the secret that
is in the victims protection domain and
that there's also a transmitter that's
associated with a piece of code and I'll
tell you a little bit more about this in
a second that
touches the secret so this transmitter
is actually running in the victim's code
and so it has permissions associated
with that right and so the basic idea is
that you if you create this this
transmitter and this receiver and you
have this channel well you've
essentially broken privacy of the victim
and so if you look at the different
attacks that are out there and so just
to give you a sense of why this taxonomy
is broad and incorporates both the
recent attacks and attacks that are
twenty years old let me give a sense of
an age-old attack that was done about
twenty years ago on the RSA encryption
algorithm where it has conditional
execution I'm depending on what the bit
of key is you either do your modulus or
not roughly speaking and that you do a
lot of computation in one case going
left and you don't do very much going
right and that this is a problem because
this is part of the algorithm and this
algorithm is actually doing different
things based on the secret key I mean it
has to because obviously the output has
to depend on the secret key but if you
haven't written the program in such a
way you could be in a situation where
you regardless of speculative execution
you're you're just doing more work on
the left-hand side where's the
right-hand side and the micro
architectural channel associated with
the cache I could change the execution
corresponding to what the execution
would be if the secret key the secret
key bit where zero versus one so this
change with respect to going left or
right is exfiltrated through the cache
tag channel based on caches and cache
misses that can be viewed by the
attacker so you can get a sense of what
the victim's cache hits and cache misses
are based on what your cache hits on
cache misses are if you shared the cache
and so this was an attack that was done
20 years ago and the fix with this
attack is something that mark mentioned
you can try to do oblivious execution by
balancing paths etc and you can
certainly do this for RSA but as you'll
see cryptographic algorithms got a lot
more complicated and these attacks are
still valid in in the case of anonymous
attestation schemes like SGX and I'll
get to that a little bit later now you
can take this
tax corresponding to Spector and
meltdown and you can view this in this
taxonomy by thinking about meltdown as
being something where the attacker was
able to write this transmitter by
essentially creating a permissions check
before accessing some data and because
of speculative execution and that data
was actually accessed and brought into
the cache in a particular corner case
before the permissions check was
actually validated and so that was a
corner case in the processor pipeline
that corresponded to the meltdown bug
inspector is a broader class of attack
where you can actually synthesize this
transmitter by looking at victim code
it's it's broader it's also harder to
accomplish but it's something that it
clearly has been done at least in in
let's say in the test tube level if not
in the wild and so these things are are
things that just from a pure standpoint
are things that you need to fix if you
want architectural isolation the way it
was promised to us you know fifty you
know sixty years ago so how do you
defend against these types of attacks
I'll just focus on the cache Channel
because that's the most popular channel
for exfiltration and it's a matter of
carefully designing processor caches in
this case to do perfect isolation right
and so people have done cache
partitioning and there there's cache
partitioning schemes that are in
processors and in general to protect
against these attacks the different
schema would be that you have to block
one of these steps I mean you gotta
break that pipe there and we've focused
on in our research focused on blocking
the channel that seems like the easiest
thing to do but there's other ways of
defending as well and so intel has cache
allocation technology built in it's
abbreviated cat and essentially it's
something that is a quality of service
mechanism it wasn't meant for security
but it's a way of making sure that a
runaway process doesn't trash the cache
for you and you still get performance
even though you're using only part of
the cache you at least get one part of
the cache now computer architecture 101
caches are made up of sets and ways you
can think of the sets as being
horizontal rows but what you see here
are different colors
the ways and essentially a way is
something that says if you have two ways
then you can either go here or there in
a particular set and it's associativity
and so you can partition the cache using
sets or using ways cat does it using
ways and it says that you can
essentially say that the attacker cannot
evict a piece of data from the victim's
way that's essentially what kab does
it's the quality of service mechanism
I'm not quite enough for for isolation
for perfect isolation for a couple of
different reasons the first is that I
shared addresses are visible so it's
possible that the that you have some
shared libraries and the victim and the
attacker could be sharing data and that
corresponds to add data that's in the
victim's way for example to get the
victim access is first and so it's
possible that that would that won't get
evicted but you can you can see the
cache hits associated with these shared
addresses and then the other part of is
just a little bit more subtle is that
you have replacement policies associated
with these caches LR user is the policy
that you learn about in computer
architecture 101 least recently used but
nobody builds LRU at least not perfect
LRU they approximated and it turns out
that replacement metadata can leak
information even though you had
isolation in the waist or you had
isolation in the sets so I'm not going
to go into gory details here but roughly
speaking the reason one of the first
reason that cat leaks information and it
doesn't protect you is simply that cache
hits are not isolated across domains so
in the shared addressed case if if an
attacker brought a piece of shared data
into its way the victim will hit on it
and if the attacker didn't and then the
victim would miss on it and so you get
some information from that and then
because you use approximate LRU schemes
even though you have this partitioning
of blue and red over here the first
three columns here or the slots
correspond to one domain the red one
corresponds to a different domain and
you can think that this isolation but if
you have an approximate LRU scheme a PL
ru pseudo LRU which is used to
quite commonly in various processors
it's possible that you can sense a
difference in what was evicted from the
victim even though you had this
isolation because of the replacement
policy at having not having in perfect
isolation so so cat doesn't protect you
and so we had to improve it and and so
we said well we'll call it dog right so
we want to be it's just an abbreviation
dynamically allocated way guards it's
it's a way of taking the cat mechanism
and fixing these two things that have
that I've told you about and just
briefly I just have one slide on it you
have to track global protection domains
you have to be very careful about what
goes into the cache and what gets
evicted from the cache and you can do
this by essentially making sure that
cache tags or replacement metadata don't
interfere with each other it's a fairly
simple change hardware manufacturers
will tell you that this is an invasive
change to the hardware because you're
you're messing with the cache hash
function etc but I am a proponent of
open source and clean slate design so
for us it's it's easy but it's not
something that can't be done any change
in hardware obviously takes years to
deploy but this is not something that
would be as invasive I would say as
changing the processor of pipeline and
changing the number of stages for
example and so roughly speaking you have
additional data associated with what
gets evicted and what gets pulled into
the cache and also the replacement
policy but perfect LRU does not have a
problem random replacement doesn't have
a problem but you if you use an
approximate LRU scheme you have to do a
little bit more work to ensure perfect
isolation and so now you'd say okay this
was the cache tag Channel and I'll just
leave you with this all this other
microarchitecture estate including
branch predictor state that needs to be
isolated if there were attacks that were
potent enough to exfiltrate through
those channels and you could use this
type of technique over there again you
have to look very carefully at what you
bring in to the how you modify the micro
architectural state there's a little bit
of a complication the unfortunate part
of the the dog scheme that we derived is
that you're not not you're this
hits across protection domains so if you
have some shared addresses then it's
possible that these shared addresses
would be replicated across ways so the
same address in two different ways of
the cache and this is okay for read-only
data
but obviously it would be a problem if
you had if you guess wrong and the data
was was writable and so you have to do
some work with the operating system to
try and fix that so let me close by just
briefly telling you about the about what
the challenges are in building secure
enclaves and speculative processors and
there's been this material covered you
know a couple of different ways so very
briefly we want to shrink the trusted
computing base you you don't want all of
the operating system to be trusted you'd
like to minimize that to perhaps as
security monitor as is the case in
sanctum or the microcode as is the case
in Intel SGX SGX has some nice
properties associated with it it does
all of these things and shrinks the
trusted computing base but it has some
serious issues associated with side
channels it leaks privacy in many
different ways
Microsoft had a very nice paper that was
mentioned on the leak through the page
tables through the page fault mechanism
but there's there's other ways and
hyper-threading for example is is yet
another way and we've already talked
about speculation unfortunately all of
these things have gotten to the point
where now you can take SDX machines of a
release number has it since I haven't
read the paper but it's going to come
out August 14th and you can extract
private keys from SDX machines when the
machine is running anonymous attestation
using a PID because those Pat's that I
talked about back in the RSA example
weren't completely balanced and
therefore these micro architectural
channels exfiltration through the cache
and also through out of order execution
so a subset of the people who did the
Spector attack are published this paper
that's going to come out as I mentioned
on August 14th and using security which
are essentially breaking the scx
ecosystem and I think the title of the
paper is something like extract
the keys of the Intel SGX kingdom or
something like that so so that's not
that's not very satisfying obviously so
there's this work to be done so this
wasn't because we were smart they was
probably more because we were lucky that
we decided that we would build
speculative non-speculative processors
way back when when we started our
sanctum project speculation is hard to
build in hardware we knew about a whole
bunch of other attacks and I don't know
of a way of isolating hyper-threaded
applications from each other so we
decided we wouldn't do hyper threading
either but we did definitely look into
the cache tag channels and we have
partition caches and sanctum and we
clean up after ourselves in terms of the
time shared processes I want to say a
little bit about Shang Tsung's chain of
trust Don mentioned this so the idea
really here is that you build processors
that have again public keys and private
keys associated with them the way it
works in sanctum is that no one knows
the private key it's generated randomly
I've been that ship is fabricated our
ship is powered up I should say or on an
FPGA and privilege doesn't imply trust
but you do have machine mode where this
small piece of code called the security
monitor runs and it essentially verifies
all of the allocation decisions that the
operating system makes and you can get
secure enclaves using this mechanism and
of course the key question is what's
your threat model did you incorporate
all of the attacks that are possible
today in the threat model and did you
design for that and it's simply armor
and ammunition it's going to keep going
I I don't see an end to that again don't
mention this the page fault attack is an
important attack it's I would say a
design flaw and SGX we fix it a couple
of different ways in sanctum versus
Keystone in in sanctum there's two sets
of page tables the enclave page tables
are inside of Enclave memory so that's
what fixes this page fault attack in the
sense that you can't see those addresses
but there's other ways of doing it
including as Don mentioned using the
physical memory protection primitive in
RISC five and so just to give you a
sense of what it takes to build an
enclave and I've shown you this picture
obviously
not possible here but the colors are
what you want to look at those are the
things that changed really the
interfaces we needed reset logic for all
of the orange colors and then we need to
add a little bit of logic corresponding
to the blues right so it's about a two
percent change this is what I meant by
it's not invasive at least from my
standpoint in terms of actually taking a
processor or a stock processor and
putting on slaves on it and so let me
just tell you about status and close
sanctum is released it's a has limited
functionality but it provides secure
enclaves you could run it on Amazon Web
Services f1 instances that have FPGAs we
invite you to if you haven't done an
official release yet but that's
happening John mentioned Keystone which
is against next generation I I would
definitely like to look at building
speculative out-of-order processor it's
not going to be very high performance
because it's academic work but it's
interesting from a standpoint of what
does it take to go build something
that's resistant to specter meltdown
attacks without the cop out of saying
well we don't do speculation so we
protect against them
Adam Chapala I gave a nice talk
yesterday about his system as Corp
system and he's doing open-source
cryptographic primitive verification we
have open source hardware it'd be
wonderful if we could marry those two
and Adam and I and an Arvin that MIT
have a DARPA project on doing that so
that's all I had
thanks for attention thank you right and
then somebody is Bill polish and so on
and and traditionally have been lousy at
making sure that software people use
things correctly maybe we're missing the
right we have documenting things tools
automatically change the most canonical
example is that you know we thought that
always and user theaters never get mixed
with each other then some always
personal photos a huge you know caching
optimization or something and mapped the
whole kernel data into the user address
space and you know very small down and
ten Spector okay any ideas about how to
automatically check for unsaved user to
encourage people to use this mechanisms
the right way yeah so you know I think
if you look at
these these the Native Client type
approaches right I mean you know that's
the best answer I have where I think you
want a runtime inside of the secure
Enclave and I think Don may have
mentioned this as well in in passing the
inside of the secure Enclave or actually
no it was Mark who had this picture
inside of the secure Enclave that's
actually sanitizing you know what this
Enclave does and so so now I'm a
hardware person I do not want to write
that piece of software but but I think
that you you you want to have
essentially an environment that
unintentional errors misleading written
programs but you also his programs
sometimes do silly things and if you
want to protect people from their
silliness you you have to you know have
some sort of layer on top of it so I
think that's kind of the right way of
doing it right okay good
don't just said do it in Oasis okay all
right right we have time for one more
question while I plug in the power to my
laptop
no more questions
one question yes hyper-threading run
than a normal and a normal processor how
much slower is the processor without
speculation and all right thank you very
much thank you again
so our next speaker is a peter peter is
a professor at Imperial College London
Peter leads the large-scale data and
systems group in the Department of
computing he has done a lot of research
on scalable reliable secure large-scale
software systems including publications
at a impressive range of conferences
including OSD Ivy LDV
and SDI and many others so we're very
fortunate to have him here and talk
about ethics thank you all right all
right thank you very much for the
introduction right now
okay um so what I would like to talk
about today is some work that we've been
doing over the last couple of years and
thinking how to provide systems support
for trusted execution in a cloud
environment and and so so what got us
excited about the trusted execution
model that it essentially well deals
with a problem that that a tenant can
move to a cloud environment without
having to implicitly trust that cloud
provider but the question here becomes
what systems support needs to exist in
that cloud environment so that you can
actually move existing workloads and so
so the issue is that a cloud tenant
would effectively think of the cloud
environment as an untrusted black box so
there's a very large and complex stack
that the cloud provider runs with
millions of lines of code and obviously
this is where a large number of security
issues can come from so when you have
vulnerabilities in the hypervisor in the
US kernel and so on they can be
exploited with large range of attacks
and then similarly there's the issue of
insider attacks where people who have
privileged access to the cloud
environment themselves can then
compromise the tenant applications and
actually when you think about existing
hardware security mechanisms that we
have they don't really try to address
this problem directly because the
regular model is that the cloud provider
actually doesn't trust the cloud tenants
a lot of the isolation mechanisms that
we have
they're all about protecting the
privileged part of the cloud
infrastructure from tenant applications
but this is essentially what the what
the clout and wants is is the reverse so
this is what we thought is exciting
about trusted execution that it's a
dedicated security feature that actually
gives control to cloud tenants to
protect their applications and their
data and and so so one way to see see
this when you look at SGX is an
implementation of trusted execution it's
actually a user space concept right so
you don't need to be a privileged
process if you want to create an enclave
and that Enclave memories that encrypt
it and integrity protect it and only the
the protected code can access that
memory but the hardware will prevent
access from higher privileged parts of
the environment such as the u.s. kernel
or the hypervisor right so so cloud
tenant can directly ideally take
advantage of this Hardware feature but
the question becomes well so if you are
a cloud tenant you want to move a
particular workload to a cloud with
trusted execution you want to take
advantage of this model well how can you
do this without modifications to your
application right so so the question
here is what is the the support that
should exists in that cloud environment
so that people can actually use trusted
execution or until SGX so what we've
been doing is exploring this design
space of different types of systems
support that we could offer to cloud
tenants and they're kind of a couple of
things that one can do so so probably
one of the earliest approaches that was
proposed I would call the library OS
approach so this is represented by work
that Microsoft did on a system called
Haven where you effectively take an
application with all of its dependencies
and an entire library operating system
and you place this inside of an SGX
Enclave so then you have effectively a
self-contained way of supporting that
application inside of the Enclave and
then you're only exposing a very thin
hyper core like interface
to the outside to do well some low-level
i/o operations where you rely on the
outside environment so when you think
about this model it has a very clearly
defined interface to the outside but you
potentially have a large trusted
computing base because of the library
operating system all of the systems
support that you're putting inside
inside of the Enclave so we've been
exploring that model with the system
called sjx LTL that I'm going to talk
about more in a moment that there is a
library always for supporting unmodified
Linux binaries that execute in SGX
enclaves so another way of designing
systems support is is to take a slightly
different approach where you reduce the
trusted computing base by only placing
the application it's library
dependencies and the standard c library
inside of an SJ X Enclave and so this is
something that we've explored in a
system called arm scone that does this
force supporting Linux applications
inside of SJ x enclaves so now the
interface that you exposing to the
outside world is essentially the system
call interface so it's a much broader
interface there more calls that are
exposed but you've reduced the trusted
computing base because inside of your
Enclave you only have a standard C
library but you no longer have the
library operating system and then
finally you you can think of
partitioning your application it's sort
of the the furthest that you can go in
terms of reducing the trusted computing
base so here what we're doing is we're
taking an application we're only taking
the security sensitive functions of that
application and this is what we're
placing inside of the s3 X arm Enclave
and then we have an application-specific
interface to the outside world of
function calls so that the security
sensitive functions can interact with
the rest of the application that runs
outside so this gives us a small trusted
computing base but it does also incur a
more complex interface to the outside
world
and so the SDK that Intel release for
creating SGX applications follows that
model essentially gives you an RPC like
mechanism for placing some functions
inside of an of an enclave so a piece of
work that we've done is there is a
framework called Glamdring that also
talked a little bit about that tries to
help developers making the decision
which functions from the application to
place inside of an STX Enclave and what
to execute outside ok so let's talk a
little bit more about the library os
approach so what are some of the
challenges with that so one significant
challenge is performance because Enclave
transitions by themselves they are
expensive because the well the hardware
has to perform particular checks
whenever execution transitions in and
out of an enclave and since we have to
exit an enclave whenever we want to
invoke a system call we will naturally
incur those expensive transitions when
we run a particular workload and so this
performance over it can be quite
significant so this is an experiment
that we did where we measured the rate
at which we can execute system calls
when we increase the number of threads
comparing native execution with SGX and
you can see that you're losing about an
order of magnitude in terms of
performance when you have s3x enclaves
so for a system called heavy workload
this is a significant problem so what
can we do about this well so so one
obvious idea is simply to reduce those
this number of Enclave transitions so
try to avoid exiting an enclave and
instead have threads stay inside of of
the Enclave so the more we can say
inside the the less we suffer from that
performance cost so how can we do this
well so one thing that we've done we use
user level threading inside of sgx
enclaves so instead of relying on on
Hardware threats and preemption we have
user level threading and those threats
essentially never exit the Enclave and
instead we have a schedule ax inside of
the Enclave that switches between those
threats and that results in a
significant perform
benefit and the other thing is to move
some OS functionality inside of of the
Enclave right so thread synchronization
is one example memory management file
system signal handling and so on so
things that normally would invoke a
system call the interaction with the
outside arm operating system if you can
move this inside of the Enclave you
avoid those expensive exits so this is
so these are the ideas that we then
realized as part of SGX lkl that
provides system support for Enclave so
as Jake's lql can run unmodified Linux
applications so you take an application
also for all of its dependencies you
provide this an encrypted filesystem
image and you can then launch it inside
of an of an enclave and so the way a
shaykhs lkl provides a library operating
system that it actually uses the Linux
kernel as a library so it uses space on
something called lql than an external
library which is an architecture
specific port of the Linux kernel and we
can run this entirely in user space
inside of an enclave so by doing this we
for example get a trustworthy file
system and a network stack that we can
then explore it in for for SGX
so there are a couple of interesting
features in the SGX lkl design so so one
is that user level threading so we can
do thread synchronization within
enclaves without exiting so if a few
ticks implementation inside of of an
enclave that we can use for this so the
other thing that we do we support
asynchronous system calls
so whenever the application actually
needs to execute a system called because
we have user level threading we can
ensure that the system call requests is
simply put into a queue that shared with
the outside and we can show you the
different different threat while we're
waiting for the result of that system
call and that can also improve
performance and this is a technique that
we've also explored in the in the work
on scone and then finally we have a
custom memory allocator where we
essentially
to our own memory management both for
the colonel and the Enclave application
inside so one picture on the STX lkl
architecture so this is what an enclave
looks like when we're running an
application so we have that encrypted
filesystem image with with the
application that we want to run and then
we have the LPL library inside of the
Enclave and in addition also a standard
c library so when we are launching in an
application using SJ excel yell in an
enclave we we will first create that
Enclave we will then load L key L we
will boot the lk l kernel inside of the
Enclave and then the kernel will mount
the encrypted disk image with the
application and it will invoke a dynamic
linker loader to then load the binary
into the Enclave so when the application
then executes its then can invoke
functions of the standard c library and
then whenever those functions need to
run a system call then this will then go
become a function call in l ki l and it
will execute the functionality within lk
l if then lk l needs to interact with
the actual hardware because for example
it needs to do an i/o operation to read
a disk block or it needs to send a
receive a network packet this is then
done through a set of shared queues that
we have with the outside world using our
asynchronous system call mechanism and
and so this gives us a significant
performance improvement compared to a
model where we would exit the Enclave
there are a couple of other things that
we had to worry about so another one is
signal handling so we need to have
signals support but the problem here is
that whenever the process receives a
signal it's actually delivered to the
outside so what we do is register a
permissive signal handler on the outside
and then demultiplex the signals inside
so that we can deliver them to the
correct user level threats inside of the
SJ accompli
so with this model we can now provide a
trusted Linux file system inside of the
sjx Enclave we can actually support any
file system that is that is included in
the Linux kernel and for the encryption
integrity protection of the file system
we can use standard Linux facilities
like for example the the device mapper
API for for encryption and integrity
protection so similarly for the network
stack we can do the same thing so so we
can support any Network protocol that is
supported by by the Linux kernel and
then the actual
encryption of packets can happen lo at a
low lower layer in the network stack so
we can use may a true or layer-3
encryption of the of the raw packets so
when we so when you look at the
interface that we're exposing to the
outside world it's quite a thin
interface so we can subdivide the calls
into workload independent host calls so
they're there cause that effectually
will be called during the boot up of lql
but they are independent of the
application workload that we're running
and then we have some work load
dependent calls so mostly related to
block IO and Network IO so so the the
reason why this distinction is is is is
sensible is that obviously that host
interface itself is a size Channel so we
need to worry about protecting those
workload dependant host calls and
ensuring that they don't leak any
information about what is happening
inside of the Enclave and this is for
example one piece of ongoing work that
we're doing is that we are asking the
question can we make this host interface
itself oblivious so can we make sure
that that an attacker that will observe
the entire sequence of host calls will
not learn anything about what is
happening inside of the sjx Enclave so
as Jake's lkl is available as open
source on on github arm so you can you
can play around with it you can launch
Linux binaries from from an Alpine Linux
image and the other interesting thing is
that we have support for managed
language runtime so you can use SGX lql
to run the java virtual machine or the
v8 JavaScript engine so you can
effectively run java applications inside
of SGX enclaves
okay so this is an example of using a
library operating system to support on
cloud applications now let's look at the
the other extreme of partitioning an
application so why is there an
interesting thing to do well so what
about if you want to run a really large
cloud application inside of an SGX
Enclave right so let's say we want to
support I know Apache spark inside of an
ST accompli so here we're looking at a
large amount of code if we place all of
this inside of an enclave for example
using SJ x lql we're potentially looking
at many vulnerabilities that would be in
that code base so instead what we would
like to do is simply identify the
security sensitive parts which is the
data that we're processing and the job
implementation that the the task
implementation of the analytics job that
we are that we're running and so in the
research community the many examples
where people have partitioned
applications for SGX manually um so
we've done some work on a system called
secure keeper that partitions zookeeper
into into amps security sensitive part
in an untrusted part Microsoft did some
work on partitioning MapReduce so there
many examples where people do this by
hand but what we interest what we were
interested in is can we help developers
to ideally automatically determine the
minimum functionality that needs to be
run inside of an SGX Enclave to achieve
to enforce a particular security policy
so so we've created a hjx partitioning
framework called glam drink and it's a
compiler based framework for
partitioning C applications at the
source code level and it works by
executing a number of steps so it relies
on a developer first annotating what the
security sensitive parts are that should
be protected so this is essentially the
security policy that a developer needs
to express so once they've done this
there's static analysis that we perform
at the source code level to then
understand which parts of that
application they need to be protected
and then we rely on sources
source transformation to create the
enclave part of the application and the
untrusted part so let's briefly look at
this in a bit more detail so first we
need to provide the annotation and this
is simply a source level annotation so
in the example of spark let's say you
want to protect the data that initially
is encrypted and sits on on HDFS so arm
say you would provide an annotation in
the spark code before it's being read by
the by the framework so you can add a
pragma that says that data is sensitive
and should be protected throughout the
execution of the application so the way
we then use those annotations is that we
use them as part of the static analysis
to figure out how to partition the
application so we generate the program
dependence graph that captures all of
the data and control flow dependencies
between different parts of the program
and we start our analysis at the at the
particular nodes that were annotated by
the developer and to ensure data
confidentiality we're interested in
everything that is affected by sensitive
data so we do a forward data flow
analysis to enforce a integrity policy
we essentially do the reverse so we do a
back foot a backward data flow analysis
to understand everything that may impact
a particular result that we want to
protect and so then what we need to
place inside of the Enclave is
essentially the union of that analysis
and and and this is then what we
consider to be part of our trusted
computing base so we then automatically
rewrite the source code to implement
that partitioning and we do this using
the LLVM compiler to chain by then
rewriting the application and
essentially adding the appropriate
Enclave and outside calls so that we can
do the transitions when we move control
in and out of an of an enclave there's
actually one last step that we need to
deal with in this has something to do
with the fact that we rely on static
analysis for this partition
so static analysis obviously makes
assumptions about for example valid
execution and the semantics of the
programming language the problem is that
an attacker has complete control over
code that lives outside in particular
they could violate those invariants the
static analysis used and so therefore we
need to make sure that whenever control
moves into the Enclave those invariants
actually hold and the way we achieve
this is by adding runtime checks that
simply verify that the the partitioning
is still sound based on the assumptions
of the static analysis made so one slide
on some results so how well does this
work well so we did an evaluation with
three applications memcache D digital
bit box which is a Bitcoin wallet and
Libra Susilo TLS implementation and we
applied Glamdring to partition the
application and the outcome was that
between 22 to 40 percent of the
application is then placed inside of the
Enclave and the rest is outside so
obviously there's no magic here depends
ultimately on how your application is
structured how powerful your static
analysis is to and and and this will
then determine how big the trusted
computing base will be but it's
definitely a way of helping a developer
to effectively obtain a principled way
to decide which functionality they want
to protect using and SGX arm Enclave
so to summarize so trusted execution in
in in in our eyes has a lot of promise
in terms of dealing with real-world
cloud security problems today but at the
same time it also creates new challenges
in terms of system support and also
tools support to take and port
applications that we have and and secure
them using trusted execution and so if
tenants want to run unmodified existing
applications so approaches that for
example use library operating system can
help with doing this and effectively
doing it transparently but at the same
time it is also important to think about
how to integrate a probe
tools with development environments for
new types of applications and in the
work that we've done Glamdring with
static analysis is one example of
achieving this ok so this is all I
wanted to share and I'm very happy to
take any questions thank you thank you
Peter
I have time for a couple of questions
yeah yeah I mean so the thing to keep in
mind with with trusted execution models
so I guess GX is that they don't really
have a they don't focus on availability
right I mean so they don't give you any
guarantees in terms of availability so
an outside attacker that for example
controls the scheduler the operating
system can simply withdraw resources
from the Enclave the Enclave relies on
the outside scheduler to run right so
effectively the Enclave cannot launch in
denial of service attack because it's
it's it's it's juggling relies on the
outside operating system but in general
in all of those approaches they can't
they can't defend against denial of
service attacks
one more question
yeah yeah well I mean it's actually not
as bad as one would think because
obviously one advantage of Linux is that
it has been optimized for embedded
architectures and essentially it can run
in low memory footprint so so if we if
we run sjx lql we can fit it within
current EPC size it's actually quite
quite comfortably so it fits so it uses
less than 96 megabytes for some of the
larger applications we will run out of a
PC memory so we will use SGX paging and
the other performance very much depends
on whether you're working set will fit
within the EPC or not and again for some
workloads that's the case obviously once
you I know run complex Java applications
with the JVM yeah I mean at some point
with the current sheikhs implementations
and the memory limits you will you will
see lower performance but this is but
there's no fundamental reason why as
future SGX implementations could not
have larger APC sizes right thank you
very much let's thank all the speakers
and this concludes the session thank you
[Applause]